[jazzy standard music]
- ♪ WOULD YOU
LOOK AT THE TIME? ♪
- ♪ YOU SHOULD JUST
STAY HERE TONIGHT ♪
- ♪ I'VE HAD TOO MUCH WINE ♪
- ♪ YOU WILL LEAVE
AT FIRST LIGHT ♪
- ♪ IT ISN'T THAT FAR ♪
- ♪ BABY,
JUST STAY WHERE YOU ARE ♪
- ♪ BACK TO MY PLACE ♪
- ♪ YOU CAN'T ESCAPE
FROM MY EMBRACE ♪
- ♪ I REALLY
HAD A VERY NICE TIME ♪
- ♪ LET ME JUST
REFILL THAT WINE ♪
- ♪ BUT I REALLY NEED TO
JUST SAY GOOD-BYE ♪
- ♪ I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE YOU TRY ♪
- ♪ PLEASE UNLOCK
THIS DOOR ♪
- ♪ IT'S LOCKED
FROM THE OUTSIDE ♪
♪ BABE, YOU'RE MINE TONIGHT ♪
- ♪ I CANNOT STAY TONIGHT ♪
♪ LOOK, I REALLY HAVE TO GO ♪
- ♪ NO, YOU REALLY
HAVE TO STAY ♪
- ♪ HEY, "NO" MEANS NO ♪
- ♪ THAT IS WHAT
THEY ALL SAY ♪
- ♪ YOU'RE HURTING MY ARM ♪
- ♪ I WON'T CAUSE YOU
ANY HARM ♪
- ♪ LET GO OF ME ♪
- ♪ WE CAN MAKE THIS HARD
OR JUST EASY ♪
- ♪ A WOMAN ALWAYS
COMES PREPARED ♪
- ♪ OOH, I'M REALLY SCARED ♪
- ♪ I SAID THIS IS
NOT WHAT I WANT ♪
- ♪ WHY YOU HAVE TO
BE SUCH A-- ♪
- ♪ I KNOW SELF-DEFENSE ♪
- ♪ I DARE YOU TO TRY IT ♪
- ♪ I DON'T WANT TO FIGHT ♪
- ♪ BITCH,
YOU ARE MINE TONIGHT ♪
♪ ♪
♪ PLEASE,
JUST PLEASE GO AWAY ♪
- ♪ I THOUGHT THAT YOU
WANTED ME TO STAY ♪
- ♪ WELL--WELL,
I JUST CHANGED MY MIND ♪
- ♪ THINK I'LL JUST
STAY AND UNWIND ♪
- ♪ HOW DID THIS ALL SWITCH? ♪
- ♪ NOW YOU ARE... ♪
♪ MY... ♪
♪ BITCH ♪
- ♪ PLEASE JUST
BE KIND TONIGHT! ♪
- ♪ NOW YOU'RE MINE... ♪
♪ TO... ♪
♪ NIGHT ♪